multi-layer perceptron is a classic
feed-forward artificial neural network
it is one of the core component of some
deep learning algorithms
not all algorithms in deep learning use
a feed-forward artificial neural network
but many do another way to look at this
is that a multi-layer perceptron is a
connected series of nodes
where each node represents a function
this connected series of node
create what is called a directed acyclic
graph
meaning that there is directionality
between the nodes and no node will ever
be revisited
this all starts with an input layer
let's use the titanic dataset example
there are four nodes here and each node
would represent a feature that we want
to use to predict whether somebody
survives or not
these could be age ticket class cabin
and sex
next there's a hidden layer that we're
representing with five nodes here
but this hidden layer could contain ten
nodes a hundred nodes
or even a thousand nodes now each of
these nodes represents some function
what happens is we take each of our
input nodes representing features
and we pipe those into each node in the
hidden layer
what's happening here is each node or
function in the hidden layer is getting
each input feature
so age ticket class cabin and sex are
passed into each node in the hidden
layer
you could view each of these nodes as
something like logistic regression
so more or less a logistic regression
model would be fit for each node made
with slightly different weights
then we have an output layer and here
we're going to have two nodes
either a person survived or they did not
survive
using the example of our titanic data
set
now we have each node in the hidden
layer outputting to each node in the
output layer
let's take a step back and just isolate
one node in the hidden layer to
understand what's happening here
you can see it's receiving the four
inputs
then this one node in the hidden layer
will basically fit some model
or learn some aspect of the data then
based on that model that it learns
it'll make some prediction about whether
somebody survived or not
maybe it's 70 percent likelihood that
they survived 30 percent likelihood that
they did not
that's just one individual node in the
hidden layer
the same process can repeat for each of
the five nodes in the hidden layer
and you get a final prediction of the
likelihood of a given person surviving
as you can imagine these can be
incredibly powerful
as you see in this example you're
essentially aggregating the predictions
of five different models altogether
this allows the overall model to learn
some really powerful relationships in
the data
when should you consider using a
multi-layer perceptron
up to this point we've suggested using
logistic regression and
svm only for a categorical or binary
target variable
one nice aspect of multi-layer
perceptrons is that they're really
powerful for both classification and
regression
in other words they're useful for both
categorical and continuous target
variables
as mentioned earlier the way multi-layer
perceptrons are constructed allow them
to learn very complex relationships in
the data
if you have complex relationships in
your data or all you care about is
performance and you don't care about
training time or
interpretability then this might be a
good tool for your problem
there are a lot of hyper parameters to
tune
if you want to have a lot of control
over the training process
multi-layer perceptrons might be a good
method to explore
when should you not use it multi-layer
perceptrons are a core component of deep
learning
you may have also heard that deep
learning is really good for tasks like
image recognition or time series that
does not mean
that multi-layer perceptrons are good
for these kinds of problems
there are specific algorithms within
deep learning like convolutional neural
networks
that are very good for image recognition
so you should not use multi-layer
perceptrons for this kind of work
if you care about transparency or
significance of predictors
you also shouldn't use multi-layer
perceptrons
they're kind of like black boxes you
pass in inputs and it returns
predictions
and it's quite difficult to understand
what's going on internally that is
generating those given predictions for
any model
this is another algorithm just like svm
that isn't great for a quick benchmark
model
multi-layer perceptrons require more
hyper parameter tuning than some other
algorithms
so you need to spend time doing that
before you can expect to get a good
model
it can also take a while to train though
not quite as long as svm
so this isn't a great choice as a quick
benchmark model
lastly you should not use multi-layer
perceptrons
if you have very limited data available
they really thrive when you have a lot
of data
if you don't have a lot of data you're
probably better off exploring other
options as the time investment likely
won't pay off in performance
for instance you might be better off
with svm or logistic regression when you
have limited data
in summary multi-layer perceptrons are
often the best tool for the job when you
have a lot of data
and you really only care about
performance
but they're not ideal if you have
limited data if you don't have much time
or compute power
or you really care about the
transparency of the model in
understanding its predictions